le nouvel espace 67 a l'air bien vaste
avec quelques dizaines d'invités pour
son inauguration
mais il sera beaucoup plus achalandée
cet été quand des dizaines de milliers
de festivaliers vont le prendre d'assaut
c'est notre tout nouveau terrain de jeu
événementiel entièrement revitaliser
accessible pour les citoyens sur quatre
saisons
l'amphithéâtre de 65 mille places aura
coûté 73 millions de dollars financé par
le gouvernement du québec et la ville de
montréal
c'était un projet cher au coeur de
l'ancien maire denis coderre
mais vivement critiqué par projet
montréal quand il était dans
l'opposition il était une fois tellement
avancé au moment des élections que
l'administration de valérie plante n'a
pas eu le choix de le compléter
on a quand même eu certains gays sur la
bonification de verdure sur le site et
ça reste quand même un cycle qui va
circonscrire le touquet et événementiel
en plus des festivals organisés par le
groupe evenko comme osheaga et heavy
montréal la société du parc jean-drapeau
espère attirer de plus petits événements
qui pourraient se tenir dans
l'amphithéâtre mais aussi sur l'allée
centrale ou dans l'agora
on parle avec beaucoup de promoteurs qui
sont intéressés le mosport sveta que ce
nouveau ce est là et maintenant
mise en service donc on espère qu'on va
être capable de vous annoncer des
surprises dans les prochaines semaines
depuis de nombreuses années le bruit des
spectacles faire rager les résidents de
saint lambert
les responsables assurent que ce sera
beaucoup mieux grâce à la nouvelle
limite de 75 ou 80 décibels selon
l'événement et surtout grâce aux neuf
jours de délai ces colonnes amovible
permettront d'orienter les haut parleurs
vers le sol
ça donne nettement une meilleure
expérience client pour les gens qui
assistent au spectacle mais ça vient
aussi circonscrire toute énergie sonore
à l'intérieur de l'amphi terre donc tout
dépend dans les conditions
météorologiques on devrait avoir quand
même un son qui est nettement atténué à
l'extérieur
premier test la fête de la
saint-jean-baptiste le 23 juin puis un
concert de l'orchestré métropolitain le
ici marie claude morin radio canada
montréal